et puis ailleurs au canada les produits
dérivés du cannabis vont arriver sur les
tablettes dans les prochaines semaines
le plus important producteur du pays
canopy grotte à présenter les produits
qui s'apprête à offrir aux consommateurs
des boissons au cannabis à saveur de
concombres et de menthe de fruit de la
passion et de goyave de gingembre et de
lyme ou de bleuets il y aura aussi une
variété de chocolat de différentes
saveurs et canopy va également offrir
des cartouches pour le vha potage
sylvain charlebois et professeur en
distribution et politiques
agroalimentaires et l'université
dalhousie on le retrouve dans nos
studios de toronto ce soir bonsoir
sylvain charlebois
alors avant de parler de canopy parlons
un peu du gouvernement du québec qui
veut investir dans le cannabis médical
pourquoi on se concentre sur le cannabis
médical qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
ça mais si
son dévolu ce que séparation contrario
le cannabis médical avait déjà fait un
bon chemin avant la légalisation du
cannabis
pour des fins récréatives et c'est pour
ça que le marché s'est débloqué de plus
en plus rapidement qu'au québec c'est un
étape qu'on n'a pas passé au québec avec
annonce aujourd'hui dans le fond ce
qu'on fait c'est que on tend la main aux
différentes professions médicales pour
dire ben c'est une drogue que nous on
aimerait sanctionné con on encourage il
va y avoir de recherche donc un
encadrement pour le cannabis médical
alors il y avait un blocage
professionnels au niveau du collège des
médecins le malaise dont il faut
l'avouer
alors ce malaise là dans le fond on
entend de l'éliminer ac annonce
d'aujourd'hui
ok allons-y sur les produits comestibles
canopy donc qui présentent ces produits
2.0 comment va s'organiser tout ce
secteur de produits comestibles
il faut pas être surpris qu'on voit de
la boisson la boisson vraiment vont être
privilégiée par les différentes
entreprises c'est une façon simple et
douce de pénétrer le marché des produits
comestibles tout simplement et on y va
avec des slogans
de toutes sortes les saveurs aussi on
voit que savard attire une clientèle
plus adulte que on fait extrêmement
attention parce que santé et notre temps
assez clair là dessus on veut pas tirer
marché des enfants bien sûr on veut pas
permettent à des enfants ou à tirer afin
qu'ils puissent consommer ces produits
soit on voit que canopy fait extrêmement
attention avec la façon qu'elle qu'elle
veut commercialiser ses différents
produits là aujourd'hui
et quels sont les défis qui se
présentent pour la vente au détail de
ces produits c'est l'axé c'est l'accès
au marché
évidemment on a un système disons peu
rigide dans toutes les provinces surtout
québec ne oui il ya eu de l'abus revue
qui avait beaucoup discuté à offrir le
cannabis légal depuis octobre 2018
mais avec le temps j'avais
une fois que le marché gagne en maturité
j'ai l'impression que les choses vont se
simplifier pour les entreprises comme
comme ça qu'ils veulent justement
commercialiser des produits commercy
parce que le marché noir vaut à peu près
5 à 6 milliards selon canada il faut
l'éliminer et le marché légal
un ou deux milliards en ce moment à peu
près où en est on estime selon nos
évaluations dalhousie qu'on va atteindre
la parité le 50/50 avant 2028
oui j'ai presque dix ans avant de
commencer à dépasser le marché noir
ouais et le but premier du coira fédéral
l'époque soupçonnait gerald c'était
d'éliminer justement la marche est
licite
donc ça va prendre beaucoup de temps
donc c'est qu'est ce qui doit se passer
pour que ça aille plus vite il faut je
présume puis on pense au québec mais
ailleurs aussi à des règlements la
assouplir davantage ses règlements ben
il va pas penser un peu à
parce qu'il vient ce marché illicite là
existent et ces produits ne sont pas
réglementée c'est 6 et ses dangers
d'ailleurs le projet de loi 6,45 on a
inclus la dernière minute les produits
festifs justement pour réglementer un
marché qui était pour exploser
finalement parce qu on stimule les sens
avec le cannabis et les gens vont
vouloir ingéré la drogue rude d'inhaler
la drogue c'est mieux pour la santé
alors il va falloir probablement des se
pose la question comment on peut offrir
donner accès aux marchés plus de
produits comme estime tout à tout en
suivant les règles établies par chaque
province il ya des enjeux de santé
publique puis monsieur fils benoît
aujourd'hui disait on veut pas aller
trop vite là une question de santé avant
de faire une question de profit mais ce
que vous nous dites c'est que dans le
fond on laisse le marché noir allaient
finalement pas si con on stimule le
marché noir
dans le fond parce que on en parle c'est
dans les médias le produit légal alors
les produits illégaux s'entremêlent avec
le marché avec un marché où le cannabis
est légal donc c'est plus facile pour le
marché noir de s'adapter et de vendre un
produit qui est plus attrayant le
produit le dieu qui émane du marché noir
est moins cher et de meilleure qualité
aujourd'hui qu'avant octobre 2008
imaginer un oui convaincant dans son sac
il faut s'adapter là il vous faudra
peut-être diminuer les prix que les
provinces soit moins long
agressive par rapport aux impôts perçus
ecce terra est passé un peu à la santé
publique parce que c'est sûr que
monsieur vais exiger leur raison il faut
protéger public mais en encourageant
marché noir de prendre d'exploration en
fait tout ça fait qu'on grand merci
beaucoup c'est le même charlebois au
revoir